it's all very well the Prime Minister
admitting the government must do more to
reduce energy bills but too short photo
opportunities in the middle of October
would have much effect of the oncoming
winter first up a block of flats in West
London to see cavity wall insulation
being pumped in and the benefits of
double glazing so this is a big
difference messy we've already noticed a
difference in the ass from a warm
sitting room to the cold realities of a
Citizens Advice Bureau to hear what help
is given to people struggling to afford
heating people like Pauline Harden who
can summon barely pay her bills often
because of sickness listen to what she
wants the government to do after watch
what gets paid of to think about um you
know which bill hits the top of the pack
I'd really like it to be a lot fairer
welcome to everyone and thank you very
much for coming to play the business of
the day was a round table in Westminster
with the six big energy companies
clearly this is an absolutely vital
issue for consumers who are facing a
very difficult time at the moment with
high prices at the petrol pumps with
high food prices and all the economic
difficulties that families are facing
and obviously energy bills are
absolutely a key part of this so-called
energy summit lasted barely an hour and
a half the message from it yes we're
sympathetic but it's up at the consumer
to do their bit as well you could
probably save 200 pounds off your 13
hundred pound a year energy bill yeah by
checking yes by switching and you can
say even more if you take advantage of
the deals though I would just prefer an
isolating festive and agility clearly
didn't not just say why do you let them
mix so much money well here's the
justification for those rather large
profits last year we made 743 million
pounds that's on the record who said
this year will make significantly less
than that those profits need to fund
that investment in new sources of gas
and the new generation of power stations
which will keep carbon carbon emission
the problem for the government is
this energy companies are now private
businesses which is supposed to make the
industry more competitive although
plenty of people believe is still not
competitive enough it also limits of
course the power that the government has
to wield over them and so they must play
the bully boys behind closed doors
whilst appearing to be the concerned
parents if you like to the wider public
making fun of the energy firms can be
pretty easy pickings the government
can't be so flippant it's no easy task
convincing a shiverin out of pocket
public but you're not just blowing hot
air Alistair buncle Sky News Westminster